hello and welcome back to the stronger
by science podcast my name is Eric
Trexler and today's episode is going to
be a special solo episode and the reason
for that if you've been following along
the last few episodes we are doing a bit
of a special series of episodes leading
into the new year because obviously this
is a time where people are really
getting ready to set a bunch of new
goals and hopefully start making some
really big strides toward those goals so
in this series what we've been trying to
do is just kind of work from the
beginning
and cover a lot of the foundational
information that someone needs when
they're either just getting into fitness
or if they're really getting ready to
revamp and kind of revitalize their
approach to Fitness uh as the new year
begins so for example we've already done
an episode covering goal setting then we
did an episode covering motivation and
behavior change and uh you might
remember back in episode 103 Greg did a
segment on Miss applications of popular
weight loss advice
today's episode is going to be different
but it's kind of in the same vein as
that episode 103 segment so in today's
episode I'm going to cover some of the
most common questions about weight loss
diets uh and so one of the things that's
uh interesting about about the podcast
is we have often lamented uh very
publicly that sometimes our episodes get
very long right and so sometimes someone
will come to us and say hey where do I
find information to get me started with
this particular goal
and sometimes you have to say well
there's a two-hour episode on this topic
and a two hour episode on that topic and
you start putting together this list of
what they would need to kind of go
through to get started and you start to
say okay well that's that's about 14
hours worth of material it's kind of a
kind of a heavy lift to give someone
when they're uh just trying to kind of
get a comprehensive idea of how to get
started so this episode like I said I'm
going to cover a lot of common questions
about weight loss diets the reason being
around the new year a lot of people do
tend to Target weight loss as a goal it
doesn't make weight loss better or worse
than any other Fitness goal you might
have but it's a really common one so we
wanted to do an episode where we tie
together a lot of topics that we've
covered in the past so these are topics
that we might have entire episodes or
really long segments about them where we
really dive in and drill down on some of
the the really nuanced details of you
know where these Concepts come from
mechanistically whether or not there's a
basis for them uh whether or not they
have supporting evidence in the
scientific literature and in some cases
what our anecdotal experiences are so
for today's episode like I said we're
going to be talking all about a bunch of
very common uh questions pertaining to
weight loss diets now before I get into
that as always if you like the show and
you'd like to support it there are many
ways you could do that uh first you
could like rate or subscribe wherever
you happen to get podcasts another thing
you could do is join our email
newsletter if you go to
strongerbyscience.com newsletter you can
sign up there and we do send out
research spotlights they're they're
basically very short reviews of recent
research they go out every Wednesday
straight into your inbox and we try to
make sure that they're very practical
it's our little brief research update
that you can really use and put into
action
another thing you could do is check out
our coaching program we have a lot of
really excellent coaches at Stronger by
science who do one-on-one virtual
coaching you can learn more about that
program at strongerbyscience.com
coaching you can use our discount code
at bulksupplements.com the discount code
is SBS pod SBS pod and that gets you a
five percent discount off of your entire
order and then finally you could
subscribe to the mass research review or
you could check out macro factor of
course macro factor is the diet app that
Greg and I co-developed with a really
talented team of people it's a really
fantastic Diet app a very efficient very
convenient food logging workflows really
really fantastic energy expenditure
algorithm uh it's got kind of built-in
coaching functionality so it helps guide
you along the process whether your goal
is to gain weight lose weight or
maintain weight so Mass research review
macro Factor you can check out both and
we think you'll like them uh all right
so let's dive into some of these common
questions about weight loss diets I
think the first one that you have to
cover in a conversation like this is how
do I actually set and adjust calorie
targets now if you go to
strongerbyscience.com diet it is a very
very long article that gets really into
detail about how to set up a diet from
start to finish it covers how to set and
adjust your calorie targets how to
identify macro targets
and it doesn't just tell you how to do
it or what to do it also goes into a lot
of detail about the evidence underlying
the various targets and recommendations
so
um this show in the show notes there's
going to be a lot of resources that are
linked uh and that'll give you an
opportunity to take a much deeper dive
into whichever topics you'd like to
really uh really key in on and dig into
some of those nuanced details so when it
comes to setting and adjusting calorie
targets there are three primary methods
that people like to use
uh one that is less common these days
especially in the evidence-based Fitness
world is to Simply start with an
assumption of your calorie needs based
on your goal and to roll with it you
know so you would set a calorie Target
and just let it ride and that would be
your calorie Target for the entirety of
your your cutting phase your bulking
phase whatever you happen to be doing
and once again in this episode I'm going
to focus uh specifically on weight loss
goals just because of the time of year
and statistically it tends to be a very
common goal so if you look at the
medical weight loss literature this is
actually an approach that's taken really
uh really frequently so it's not
uncommon at all
to open up a study where instead of
individualizing weight loss diets the
research team might just say hey we're
going to put everyone on an 800 calorie
diet and that's the diet or we're going
to put them on a thousand or 1200
calorie diet but in many cases you will
see dietary interventions in the
literature where they just say hey 800
calories should be low enough to do it
they give the the diet usually if it's a
very low calorie diet like that they'll
actually provide either all the foods in
many cases there's going to be a lot of
supplementation involved like a liquid
kind of protein shake based diet but
that's a really popular approach in the
medical literature
um but another thing that's really
popular in the medical literature is
very very high rates of weight regain uh
very high rates of weight regain after
those Protocols are done you know so one
of the challenges with that type of
intervention or I guess one of the
shortcomings I would say is when you
just tell someone here is your diet you
give them a big box of protein shakes
and you say 800 calories a day you
literally have to do this uh for the
next 12 weeks uh over those 12 weeks
absolutely those people are very likely
to lose a substantial amount of weight
but they have not built any new skills
pertaining to weight loss or weight
maintenance they have not created any
new behaviors uh pertaining to weight
loss or weight maintenance it's kind of
this uh intervention in a box they hand
it over here's your food for the next 12
weeks and for a short time frame people
can can often make that work uh you know
when you look at these studies in the
literature in most cases there is
significant weight loss that occurs
um however it doesn't seem to be
particularly uh sustainable
but even out in the real world outside
of those study contexts there are major
shortcomings of this General approach of
just taking an assumed calorie Target
and sticking with it for the duration of
your diet
um so before I get into some of those
shortcomings uh what kind of targets are
common that's a really important
question to ask a lot of times when
people are trying to maintain their
weight and they're taking this approach
of just guessing a number usually
they're going to aim somewhere around 15
kilocalories per pound of body weight so
they calculate their weight in pounds
multiply it by 15 and that's how many
calories a day they're going to be
eating a moderate cut might be around 13
calories per pound and a pretty
aggressive cut
might be all the way down at 11 calories
per pound now if you talk to a physique
athlete who is really late in their
contest preparation really late in that
timeline and they're pushing really hard
you know their diet is as restrictive as
it's going to get during that prep phase
absolutely you're going to see people
whose calorie Target is below 11
calories per pound no question at all
um so those are just kind of basic
heuristics and a lot of times that's
when bodybuilding coaches if they are
kind of double checking themselves to
say am I being too restrictive here
sometimes they will actually kind of
calculate how many calories per pound
are we eating here and does that seem
like an appropriate value so in many
cases 11 to 13 calories per pound is
going to be a place where someone sets
their calorie Target
and they just leave it and they say for
the I'm gonna do a cut for four months
and I'm gonna eat this much a day for
the next four months now there are like
I said issues with this approach
um
in the worst case scenario it's just
simply not going to be an appropriate
calorie Target
um there is a great deal of variation in
terms of the energy needs from person to
person uh that can be impacted by things
that are somewhat predictable so for
example uh the best predictor we have of
somebody's resting metabolic rate for
example is going to be fat free Mass so
you know that is something that we know
is going to dictate some of the
variation for energy needs when we
compare one person to another a person
with higher fat free mass is likely
going to have higher energy needs and
they should have a different calorie
Target when they're cutting weight or
trying to do a weight loss or fat loss
phase
um
so
like I said there the the worst case
scenario is that because there is
variation I mean fat free mass is one
variable that can dictate these things
but it's one of many um even people with
the same exact fat-free Mass uh there's
a study by Ponce and colleagues uh not
too long ago within the last year or two
it was a study from a doubly labeled
water database where they could look at
total daily energy expenditure in Free
Living people uh and also they looked at
resting energy expenditure as well but
they were looking at these metabolic
outcomes in Free Living people and
looking at it across the lifespan
looking at various predictors for what a
person's energy needs are uh fat free
Mass was the biggest predictor of energy
needs but it was certainly not a perfect
predictor so even people with the same
fat free Mass had very very different
energy needs and therefore their energy
Target or their calorie Target during a
weight loss diet should be different
so worst case scenario you choose one of
these kind of assumed targets and it
simply may never be the right target for
you so for example it might be way
higher than it ought to be for that
individual and they will stick to that
calorie Target and simply not achieve
the weight loss that they hope to
achieve
um even in the best case scenario so we
might imagine a scenario in which the
person does select a weight Target or a
calorie Target that is appropriate for
their intended rate of weight loss
at first that's great but usually over
the course of a weight loss or a fat
loss diet
we will see that total energy
expenditure will decrease and as a
result we're going to need to go in and
actually change the calorie Target as we
go in order to keep that person on the
trajectory that they want you know so if
someone wants to lose uh you know one
pound a week uh you know at first they
might get lucky and and select uh kind
of an assumed calorie Target that does
have them starting uh at a rate of
weight loss that is you know one pound
per week
um that would be great but over time
what they're going to find is you know
as they start to lose weight their body
is going to be smaller it's going to use
less energy uh they likely will run into
some degree of metabolic adaptation so
an Adaptive reduction in energy
expenditure so you know there's a good
chance that when you use this approach
your starting Target is simply not going
to be appropriate to begin with it might
be too high so you're not losing weight
it might be too low and you're on way
too restrictive of a diet
um but even if you get lucky and you
start out with a great number uh the
most likely scenario is that over the
course of that diet uh the the number
that was perfect at the beginning is
going to start to become less
appropriate over time uh so this
approach of just picking a number and
sticking with it for the entire diet
it's viable as long as you pick an
appropriate number to begin with
um but it there is a lot of room for
error and there's no built-in mechanism
where you can really say okay at what
point am I going to adjust it and how am
I specifically going to adjust it
now the next uh approach that people
will take is to do an estimate uh they
they will use previously validated
equations to estimate their resting
metabolic rate uh they will convert that
to an estimate of their total daily
energy expenditure and then they will
aim for a percentage of that value and
so of course if weight loss is the goal
you would be looking at a percentage
that is less than a hundred percent uh
you want your energy intake to be lower
than your energy expenditure for a
weight loss goal so the way this works
is there are a number of resting
metabolic rate equations out there and
you know a lot of times people will take
that equation and they'll put in some
basic information there's all sorts of
calculators online you can put in you
know uh usually body weight sometimes
biological sex sometimes a body fat
percentage estimate
um height I mean a number of demographic
characteristics you know pretty basic
stuff and the equation will crunch some
numbers and give you an estimated uh
resting metabolic rate
after that uh typically the process
involves adjusting based on your
physical activity level so there are
some published validated
um uh correction factors where someone
with a really high activity level is
going to have a higher correction factor
than someone with a really low physical
activity level so you are using one of
these uh equations that are based on
very basic demographic information very
basic characteristics you're using that
to calculate your resting metabolic rate
or I should say to estimate your resting
metabolic rate you're multiplying by an
activity Factor
and that's going to give you an estimate
of your total daily energy expenditure
so from that point if you're trying to
do a moderate cut you know not not super
fast not super aggressive you might aim
to eat 80 to 90 percent of your
estimated total daily energy expenditure
so you would take your total expenditure
multiply it by 0.8 or 0.9 and that would
be your calorie Target starting out
um if you were doing a more aggressive
cut then the uh the number you're
multiplying by the percentage of
calories you're going for is actually
going to be lower which is obviously
quite intuitive so instead of
multiplying your total daily energy
expenditure by 0.8 or 0.9 you're
actually going to multiply it by 0.6 or
0.7 and of course it's going to give you
a much lower calorie Target so
um this is in most cases a better
approach than the assume approach
the reason being is that the resting
metabolic rate equations that do
incorporate some individualized or
personalized information tend to be
better than these heuristics that are
purely based on body weight alone
usually you can get a slightly better
prediction when you're using one of
these previously validated equations
that that at least incorporate some of
your basic characteristics and
demographic information
and then of course another thing that
that makes this approach more suitable
than the first approach is that it does
ask you to give a decent assessment of
your activity level your physical
activity so again there is a slightly
higher level of customization but we
still run into the very same challenges
as we saw with the first approach and
and that is this is slightly more
personalized and individualized but but
it's not quite customized there's still
a lot lot of room for improvement in
terms of the level of individualization
these equations that are being used the
physical activity correction factors
they work pretty well for most people
when you look at a huge group of
individuals
it can give you a nice average value but
for a single person a particular
individual this approach generally is
not going to be customized enough to get
them to a really perfect Target for them
based on their intended rate of weight
loss and there's actually a recent paper
by Rodriguez and colleagues this was out
of Grant Tinsley's laboratory down at
Texas Tech University and we we've
talked about Grant Tinsley's work a lot
uh he is a really really excellent
scientist I've had the privilege of
collaborating with him uh many times not
on this paper so I'm not giving a biased
assessment here but this paper by
Rodriguez and colleagues
I was reading through it the other day
and I wasn't very surprised by the uh
the initial uh you know they were
looking at a variety a large number of
different uh validated equations for
estimating resting metabolic rate which
of course is kind of the the first major
step in this process and some of the
equations did Okay some did worse that
wasn't particularly surprising because
that's something that we've already
known for quite some time uh but the
thing that was interesting to me was
they were looking at
um how well these equations would uh
basically account for increases in
energy expenditure that occur during
bulking right so I mentioned previously
that during a weight loss phase it's
very common and it's very expected that
we will see uh energy expenditure go
down and there will even be an Adaptive
component where energy expenditure goes
down more than we would expect based on
on the changes in body composition alone
the inverse of that is true for bulking
as well and that is something we've
talked about on the show during weight
gain phases energy expenditure tends to
go up because we are just gaining mass
we're a bigger person who burns more
calories but above and beyond that
increase there often is an Adaptive
increase in energy expenditure and this
is the first paper that I'm aware of
that that kind of took this approach to
looking at how a large number of these
equations would do in terms of trying to
account for that adaptive change in
metabolic rate and the short answer is
they didn't do particularly well and so
with this particular approach we still
have some of the same problems as the
first approach it's not necessarily
individualized and customized to the
extent that we need and even if it is
it'll be pretty good for a starting
estimate but over time
as there are adaptive changes in uh
energy expenditure and is there are
non-adaptive changes in energy
expenditure just from losing weight over
the course of a weight loss diet it's
very likely that even if you get very
very lucky and the first uh estimate for
your calorie Target turns out to be very
effective for your goal over time the
effectiveness of that Target should
necessarily get worse and worse and
worse and with within this approach
there's really uh not a great way to
account for that and to make sure that
you're updating your Target in a way
that is appropriate for your changes in
energy expenditure so
that brings us to the third uh approach
that's really commonly used which is to
observe how things are going and to make
adjustments on the fly it is an approach
that takes a little bit more effort and
a little bit more consistency in terms
of weighing yourself tracking your food
and things like that but it is perfectly
customized and it offers you an
opportunity to continue changing your
diet based on how your body is
responding so the way you would do this
is
um you know if you're already tracking
your weight and your calories
you can use your best judgment for your
starting point so for example
um you know if you already know that
you're eating 2 800 calories a day very
consistently and your body weight is
extremely stable you have a pretty good
uh estimate right now that your total
daily energy expenditure is 2800
calories you you seem to be maintaining
quite well there so that's really useful
information you already have a great
opportunity of knowing where you need to
set your calorie Target to have a you
know modest moderate or very aggressive
rate of weight loss so you already know
the energy expenditure number that
you're trying to uh to to base your
calorie Target from
now if you're not already tracking your
weight and your calories then you want
to go ahead and use that estimate that
estimation method that I mentioned
previously so you'd use kind of a
validated resting metabolic rate
equation you would use correction
factors and if you go to Stronger by
science.com diet
we do kind of talk about what correction
factors we think are best there's a set
of Correction factors that we developed
for the macro Factor Diet app that we
think are uh we believe they're a step
up from the most common
um correction factors out there just
because they're a lot more simple to use
they're a lot more straightforward so
what you would do is you would use a
validated equation my recommendation
tends to be the Cunningham equation from
1980 simply because it is
based on fat free mass and because it
has there's Empirical research
indicating that it does quite well for
for resting metabolic rate estimates in
the general population
so people who might just be getting into
fitness and do not have a prior history
of a lot of exercise or weight training
or anything like that so um it works
really well in that particular
population but it also seems to work
very well well for very muscular
physique athletes actually
write out a grant Tinsley's lab they had
a study where they compared a bunch of
different validated equations for
muscular physique athletes because
obviously their their body
characteristics are going to be very
different and so some of those
predictive equations we talked about are
not going to be as effective for that
population so the Cunningham equation
from 1980 is really nice because it
seems to work very well across a broad
spectrum of body composition ranges and
across a broad spectrum of muscularity
levels and training status so what I
would recommend if you want to do this
and you really don't know where to start
with your calorie Target I would say
best way to do it um you know we need to
have an estimate of total daily energy
expenditure
um and and so the way we're going to get
that if you haven't been tracking your
weight and your calories and you don't
know where to start what you're going to
do then is use the Cunningham equation
to get resting metabolic rate use the
macro Factor
um the physical activity correction
factors that that we published that will
give you a pretty good starting point
for your total daily energy expenditure
uh it's not going to be perfect but with
this approach I'm about to describe it's
completely okay so what you're going to
do is start with a calorie deficit that
you think is going to be large enough to
get you on track with your intended rate
of weight loss so if you want to do a
pretty moderate cut you don't want to be
super aggressive about it not in a big
hurry you want to make sure it's a
really sustainable rate of weight loss
probably want to start with losing 0.25
to one percent of body mass per a week
if you want to go a little more
aggressive of course then you could go
above one percent of body weight per
week
um and so if you use macro Factor
um you know obviously there's a lot of
logic built in in terms of helping you
identify okay how big should that
initial drop in calories be but the nice
thing about this approach even if you're
not using macro factor is you make your
first adjustment you might drop your
calories by 250 300 maybe 500 600
calories you make this first adjustment
uh or or you you know kind of aim for a
deficit of that size and all you're
going to do then is just monitor your
changes in body weight so you want to be
really consistent about weighing
yourself every morning uh to you know to
the to the extent that it's possible
you're going to miss some days here and
there that's totally fine but you want
to also be as consistent as possible
about your calorie intake
so let's say you start you run these
numbers you say okay I think I'm going
to start with a calorie intake of 2300
calories per day and I want to lose 0.5
of my body weight per week you would set
that calorie Target you would try to
adhere to it the best you can and you
would watch your body weight changing
over time and if you notice that you're
losing weight too slowly then of course
you after you give your body enough time
to actually adjust to that calorie
Target then you would say okay I'm
really convinced that this calorie
Target is too high I'm not losing weight
quickly enough for my goal I'm going to
go ahead and do another incremental
adjustment where I reduce my calories
now you might start out and say okay
um this diet feels really restrictive
I'm losing weight much more quickly than
I intended to and because of that you
might decide that you want to actually
revise your calorie Target upward you
might say this is going a little too
fast it's getting a little too
restrictive too quickly I know that I
I'm in it for the long haul with this
weight loss phase so there's a little
bit of guess and check that occurs
now I will acknowledge uh you know we
make macro Factor uh certainly we have a
bias in terms of uh we think it works
quite well uh one challenge that you can
run into with this this third approach
is without good data smoothing uh your
body weight might jump around a little
bit and it might be hard to really
understand with a high level of
confidence what your actual Trend in
body weight looks like when you see it
bouncing around down two pounds up one
pound up half a pound down two pounds it
can be very attempting to overreact to
some of these short-term fluctuations or
to Simply really struggle to get a good
sense of how your weight is truly
tracking over the last week the last two
weeks or the last month you know kind of
establishing that weight Trend can be
very difficult without the the help of
of a good software
um so you know from our perspective you
know the nice thing about macro Factor
if you choose to try it out is it'll
help you identify how big that initial
uh drop in calories should be it'll help
you identify an initial calorie Target
that should be appropriate for your goal
and even if it isn't it will continue to
update based on your rate of weight loss
or weight gain
and it'll it'll basically continue to
recalibrate and recalibrate and over a
pretty short span of time usually only a
couple weeks macro Factor can really
hone in on your true energy expenditure
and start to give you a calorie Target
that is very very very precisely in line
with your intended rate of weight loss
and the best thing is because it's
constantly re-updating its understanding
of your energy expenditure based on
changes in body weight changes in energy
intake you know you might start with a
really great Target over time you know
you might notice your energy expenditure
is going down rate of weight loss starts
to slip macro Factor will pick up on
that based on your weight Trend and it
will make the adjustment so that your
calorie Target continues to be in line
with the goal that you've set
now
um moving on to the next question
around New Year's there are a lot of
people who are going into the new year
they're setting some new goals and they
are a little bit torn because you know
they they do want to lose some fat so
maybe it's not necessarily a weight loss
diet but they want to do a fat loss diet
but they also
have a goal that involves becoming more
muscular as well over time so they want
to lose fat and they want to build
muscle historically speaking or I guess
you know traditionally when you have a
fat loss goal typically you go into a
caloric deficit it's great for fat loss
not necessarily the best for optimizing
muscle gain and then of course the
inverse is true when you want to really
prioritize muscle building you will
typically go into a caloric Surplus
you'll have a goal that involves gaining
some weight and it'll be great for
building muscle but it will not be very
suitable for losing fat at the same time
um you know and I'm talking about two
extremes but the reality is there's a
spectrum you know there there are
definitely instances where someone could
build muscle and lose fat at the same
time we don't necessarily
have to dichotomize it and say if you
want to lose fat you have to be in this
huge calorie deficit and you cannot
build muscle and we don't have to look
at the other end and say if you want to
build any muscle at all you have to be
in this huge caloric Surplus that is
going to be totally incompatible with
fat loss so that brings me to a question
which is is recomping actually possible
and recomping is kind of a fitness
industry term that is now in the
research literature as well
recomposition refers to the process of
simultaneously losing fat and building
muscle so when it comes to this question
is it possible to recomp is it possible
to lose fat and build muscle at the same
time
most people who are pretty familiar with
the evidence would say absolutely it's
possible because there is a great deal
of research indicating that people do it
but where it starts to get a bit
controversial where you start to see
differences of opinion
is when we actually really refine the
scope of the question and we say is
recomping possible for people who are
already pretty muscular and pretty well
trained and so that's a different
question entirely I think it's pretty
uncontroversial to suggest that if
someone is entering uh you know if
they're just getting into fitness
and they really don't have a lot of
muscle mass perhaps they have plenty of
body fat to lose when they start getting
into fitness they have ample
opportunities to build muscle and lose
fat it's not going to take too much for
them to build muscle you know we see
some studies where
um you know people that are particularly
inactive they might actually gain a
little a little bit of lean mass from
walking interventions or low intensity
cardio interventions so if you're very
untrained it does not take a lot to have
some degree of hypertrophy or muscle
growth occurring and then of course you
know if you have plenty of body fat to
lose it does not take a lot to start to
get body fat moving in the other
direction and see some loss of fatness
so if you ask someone is recomping
possible most folks will say absolutely
it is but some folks will say
if you have really any resistance
training experience at all it's going to
be very very very unlikely and that is a
perspective that I certainly understand
um but I would also push push back
against that um and I think the best
singular source of evidence that would
contradict that position is a review
paper by Barakat and colleagues so Chris
Barakat was the lead author of this
um he puts out some really excellent
content very very good bodybuilder
um and in the article it was a review
paper
and they basically said hey let's look
for it let's see if we can find
instances where people are really
achieving recomposition despite the fact
that they were already resistance
trained before the study began and
indeed they do point to several
different uh instances where it has been
documented uh many times and in fact
we're talking about effects that are
documented at the group level so it's
not like there's one or two outliers in
the sample who happen to do the
unimaginable we're talking about an
average group level change that is
totally compatible with a recomposition
so uh what's really interesting about
that review paper is they didn't just
provide very compelling evidence that
it's possible they also show that it's
it's not as rare as you might expect and
it occurs in a lot of different
scenarios and what I mean by that is
it's not always in people that are
losing weight and happen to gain a
little bit of muscle in the process
there are instances where people people
achieve resistant trained people
achieve recomposition when they are
having a net loss of body weight so
basically the amount of fat that they're
losing the mass of fat that they're
losing is greater than the massive
muscle that they're gaining but both are
occurring right so it's a net weight
loss but they are recomping of course
there are plenty of instances where
people are recomping but their body
weight is staying very stable so it's
not really changing by more than half a
kilogram in either direction they are
maintaining their body weight and it's
basically like hey lose a pound of fat
gain a pound of muscle you've recomped
but your body weight has stayed the same
you know the example I mentioned
previously of weight loss with recomp
that would be like losing four pounds of
fat and gaining a pound of muscle right
so the net effect is weight loss but
recomposition has occurred so they
documented instances of recomposition in
resistance trained folks
who were losing weight who were
essentially maintaining weight and even
in people who were gaining weight as
well
um and that's going to be a little bit
harder to do if you're talking about
really big changes in body composition
but absolutely there are instances where
someone might gain over the course of a
study uh two pounds of muscle and lose a
pound of fat right and so in that case
you would say okay well body weight has
gone up but fat Mass has gone down so
there is the review paper by Barakat and
colleagues that was looking more at
group level data but one thing that
dawned on me recently
um people who have been following the
show following the website for a while
will remember that back in the day we
had a series of articles about the
concept of P ratios and hypertrophy and
getting deep into that topic is probably
beyond the scope of this particular
um this particular episode and segment
but what we were looking at is body
composition changes in resistance
training interventions but we were
looking at individual level data from
the studies so instead of just looking
at the group average we actually
gathered individual level data of all
the individual participants and what
we're trying to do is kind of plot out
the relationships and figure out within
these studies you know what do these
body composition changes look like how
does it relate to uh some very specific
Baseline characteristics but it dawned
on me recently when I was uh covering
this topic for an article that we have
all this individual level data that we
used for
um a participant level meta-analysis in
that uh series of articles about P
ratios so we have you know as we're
doing this participant level
meta-analysis we gathered all this
individual level data so we don't even
need to rely exclusively on these group
level averages we can look at
individuals and say were there people in
here
who achieved recomposition while they
were losing weight or who achieved
recomposition while they were weight
stable or who achieved recomposition
recomposition as they were actually
having a net gain in body weight and
indeed within that
um large pooled data set from all those
studies that we included there were of
course examples of all of those
different things people recomping when
they were losing maintaining or gaining
weight so we have pretty strong evidence
both at the group level and at the
individual level that absolutely people
can achieve recomposition but I don't
want to be unclear about this it is
absolutely true that recomposition is
more feasible for some folks than it is
for others okay so if you think about
someone with a high potential for
recomposition so someone for whom really
substantial recomposition is a high
likelihood they would have a certain set
of characteristics so first of all they
would be engaged in a resistance
training program if you want to have
simultaneous muscle building and fat
loss of course the first thing you want
to do is make sure you're actually
lifting weights during that process
another uh characteristic or factor
contributing is someone who is new to
resistance training or has a relatively
low level of muscularity
these individuals are more likely uh
broadly speaking to have the potential
for substantial recomposition another
characteristic is very high body fat
percentage relative to the population
average if you have uh you know
relatively more fat to lose then
recomposition seems to be a more
feasible goal of course if you're
absolutely shredded
um you know your likelihood of losing
fat and being able to support muscle
gain at the same time is going to be
severely inhibited
another characteristic is it is very
common to see
recomposition that occurs depending on
overall energy status and what I mean by
that is recomposition tends to be very
accessible for people who are either
weight neutral so they're they're you
know eating a calorie intake level that
is keeping their body weight pretty
stable or if they are have having very
modest changes in body weight so for
example
someone who is totally maintaining body
weight lifting and they meet some of
those other criteria or have some of
those other characteristics
recomposition is a very feasible goal
for the for that type of individual the
same is true if they had a gradual loss
of weight or a very gradual gain in body
weight but what would be very uncommon
very atypical would be having an
enormous caloric deficit and expecting
considerable muscle gain at the same
time there is a meta-analysis uh a while
ago probably about a year or so ago
where they looked at you know the
relationship between an energy deficit
and the gains in lean mass that were
observed over the the duration of
resistance training interventions what
they found was uh you know deficits were
not particularly helpful as we would
expect for building muscle because
building muscle is an energy intensive
process we can really help it along by
making sure we're providing plenty of
calories and plenty of energy to fuel
that energy demanding process what they
found though was you know for smaller
energy deficits it wasn't particularly
uncommon to see muscle growth occurring
but as energy deficits got larger and
larger as rates of weight loss and fat
loss got larger and larger there started
to be bigger impacts by which
hypertrophy was attenuated and so uh if
you were hoping to recomp and build
muscle while losing fat you would want
to make sure that you're not in a
massive massive caloric deficit as long
as you can avoid that uh and the
opposite is true as well
um you know if you are eating enough
calories to fuel extremely rapid muscle
gain you know really large amounts of
muscle gain it's going to be quite
unlikely that you are also consuming a
calorie level that is low enough to
simultaneously facilitate fat loss and
so what we see is that if someone is
gaining weight uh very very very rapidly
it probably indicates that they're you
know their calorie intake is too high to
be supporting the simultaneous loss of
fat Mass it's just going to be very
infeasible for a drug-free natural
lifter
to be rapidly gaining muscle really
large amounts of muscle while also
losing fat at the same time so uh people
who are new to lifting have higher body
fat percentage and people who are not in
a massive deficit or a massive massive
energy Surplus these are individuals who
as long as they're lifting weights have
the highest possible potential for
recomposition and that brings me to kind
of a sub question which is really really
common around this time of year there
are a lot of folks who say okay I know
what my long-term goals are
I want to eventually be leaner than I am
now I want to have lower body fat but I
also want to have a lot more muscle than
I currently have
what do I do first do I need to cut
first do I need to bulk first should I
recomp first and the reality is it kind
of depends and physiologically there
aren't a lot of wrong answers um the
first one that we've already covered is
recomping
when someone is deciding whether or not
they want to do a recomp phase or try to
do recom recomposition they have to
really seriously consider whether or not
they're a person with really high
potential for recomping so if you're
very very lean very well trained very
muscular it's probably going to be
unlikely that you're making really
dramatic recomposition happen but you
know if you meet some of the
characteristics that I discussed
previously it's quite possible that you
can say you know what I don't know if I
want to bulk first or cut first maybe I
won't choose maybe I don't have to maybe
I'll do recomposition and when you do
that you're not going to necessarily
maximize your rate of fat loss nor are
you necessarily going to maximize your
rate of muscle gain but you can make
substantial meaningful strides toward
both goals at the same time so for some
people that's an excellent option for
other others they want to know should I
cut first or should I bulk first because
you know this this might be someone who
uh recomping is just not going to be a
high probability Endeavor for them
and physiologically there's not really a
right answer to that question
you know there have been people in the
past who have said that if you get
leaner first it will increase your
ability to put on muscle uh our our
series of articles about P ratios I
think casts a lot of very very serious
doubt on that claim I I do believe that
uh that that claim that getting leaner
will help you build muscle
physiologically I don't believe that
that claim is is supported by the best
available evidence and in fact I do
believe it's contradicted by the best
available evidence
um and so what that means and you know
that there's really no physiological
advantage of bulking and then cutting um
I mean you you could get into some
arguments about if cutting first would
make you more predisposed to Rapid
regain of fat Mass
unless you're getting absolutely
shredded that's probably not as uh it's
probably not a high priority
consideration it's probably not as
pertinent of a concern if you're just
doing a really gradual really
sustainable fat loss phase if you have a
really good plan in place it's unlikely
that you're going to be setting yourself
up for very precipitous regain of fat
after that's over so from a
physiological perspective I don't really
believe that there is a correct answer
and some people find that frustrating
they say well I wanted the right answer
and now I don't have it but in reality
the answer is that they're both right
they are both viable options cut first
in bulk later or bulk first and cut
later
and what I usually recommend people do
is think very seriously about which of
the two is most exciting to you right
now I encourage people to think very
very deeply about their priorities their
sense of urgency for one goal versus the
other and I think when it comes to
striving toward a goal
if you're really neutral and you say
well I you know I I equally want to get
leaner and build muscle I know that I
need to do both of these things but you
don't know which one to do first
usually if you follow the one that you
are currently most excited about in my
experience that tends to lead to the
best outcome so what I try to do is say
where is our intrinsic motivation
currently lying I mean right now deep
down are you more excited about losing
fat or are you more excited about
building muscle knowing that doing one
to some extent comes at expense at the
expense of the other in the short term
but you can get to the other one later
in the long term so what I usually
encourage people to do when they're
really saying I don't know if I should
bulk or cut or recomp what I usually
encourage people to do is first of all
let's figure out if you have a high
likelihood of really substantial
recomposition for some people it's not
going to be that feasible of a goal it
might be possible but it might not be a
high probability outcome
and it might be the type of thing where
they have the ability to gain half a
pound of muscle and lose half a pound of
fat and to them it technically recomp
occurred but it wasn't enough change in
either direction to really get them
excited so we want to avoid that
um so then when you start saying okay
well I'm not going to recomp should I
bulk or should I should I cut I usually
tell people physiologically it's not
going to make that big of a difference
so what that means is you should
probably do the one that you are most
excited about at this exact point in
time and you can do the other one after
the fact and then of course you know you
can oscillate back and forth between
those I I generally discourage rapidly
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth
um you know if we're talking about very
very short time scale so I would not
tell someone to go two weeks of bulking
two weeks of cutting back and forth It's
possible it's viable you can do that but
I usually like to make sure that when I
do a bulking phase I can look back and
say I made big strides during that
bulking phase I like to say I'm going to
do this bulk for five months six months
maybe nine months maybe a year you know
I really want to lean into this and
commit to it and look back and say I
easily gained seven pounds of muscle and
the same is true for fat loss phases I
don't like to do a one week cut or a
two-week cut I like to do it for months
on end so that we can look back and say
wow you know we lost 25 pounds and that
was a really really successful approach
that we took
foreign
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
now moving on the third question that
comes up a lot when we're talking about
weight loss goals and weight loss diets
the third question is how do I set and
adjust my macro targets and so for this
question once again I'm going to refer
readers back to the diet article
strongerbyscience.com diet that article
of course covers how to set a calorie
Target but it also talks about macro
targets how to set them and how you
might adjust them over time so I want to
begin with protein and I'm going to keep
this pretty brief because we had a
fairly recent episode where I talked in
a lot of detail about
protein targets for building muscle and
what My Views are and why My Views are
that way we talked about how
in the evidence-based Fitness World uh
in many cases people uh suggest that you
know it's got to be 1.6 to 2.2 grams of
protein per kilogram of body mass 1.6 to
2.2 is by far the most common range
you're going to see in the
evidence-based Fitness World or another
common one uh so 2.2 grams per kilogram
is equivalent to one gram of protein per
pound of body weight of course that's a
very very simple heuristic and
simplicity is a good thing and so I I
there's nothing wrong with the fact that
these two recommendations are very
prevalent and they are very compatible
with you know if you're following those
guidelines you're eating enough protein
to make really really solid gains so I'm
certainly I certainly would not question
that but uh in the the recent episode
about protein requirements I talked
about how in many cases uh we can make
really good gains really substantial
gains without getting all the way up
necessarily to that range of 1.6 to 2.2
2 grams per kilogram of total body mass
and another consideration I brought up
is that arguably you could say it makes
more sense to scale protein
recommendations based on fat free Mass
rather than total body mass
now I would not suggest that scaling to
fat free mass is a perfect system but I
do think it has advantages compared to
total body mass especially when you get
into ranges of people whose body
composition is very far from the
population average or very far from the
average that we see in the typical
protein study so when body fat starts to
get much lower or much higher than the
average body fat Within These studies
some of these targets start to lose
their relevance and they start to become
less and less appropriate so when it
comes to protein intake I like to set it
as categories so possibly sufficient
probably sufficient and almost certainly
sufficient and I like to scale them to
grams per kilogram of fat free Mass so
all the ranges I'm about to to discuss
here for protein are scaled to fat free
Mass so possibly sufficient in my from
my perspective is 1.5 to 1 0.74 grams
per kilogram of fat-free mass now that
for depending on your body fat
percentage that might put you in the
range of like 1.2 to 1.4 grams per
kilogram of total body mass so this is
going to be lower than the most common
ranges that you see out there it might
not always be enough to fully maximize
your gains but it should be more than
enough to make really uh satisfactory
progress toward your goals so you should
be able to make substantial gains with
that protein intake the question is will
you necessarily make 100 of the gains
that are on the table the answer is
maybe but possibly not
so this is a recommendation uh range
that would make the most sense for
someone who wants to make substantial
progress toward their their muscle
building goals or or their their goals
pertaining to retaining muscle during a
weight loss phase
um so but you know it would be most
appropriate for someone who like I said
wants to make uh substantial progress or
or you know really effectively retain a
lot of of lean body mass or fat-free
mass or muscle mass during a diet but it
might not be the perfect range for
someone who is really really focused on
optimizing that right so if it is an
absolute top priority and you would be
devastated to to leave any gains on the
table or devastated to lose any fat free
mass then you might want to bump up into
one of the higher categories but if
you're someone who really doesn't like
eating protein you're not absolutely
hyper focused on optimization and pretty
good or very good is good enough for you
um you know coupling that with your lack
of preference for a high protein diet
it's a very uh suitable protein range
for for that particular type of person
now let's say you don't mind eating
plenty of protein you'd like to make
sure you're getting a little bit closer
to absolutely you know being certain
that you're optimizing this process
um then you would take a step up and
enter that category that I call probably
sufficient so that is an intake range of
1.75 to 1.99 for most people this is
going to get you most of the gains that
are on the table
um there is some possibility that's not
going to be quite high enough to fully
optimize but we are talking about
getting the Lion's Share of gains or
during a weight loss context maintaining
the Lion's Share of muscle mass and fat
free Mass so again if you're someone
who's you know you don't have a complete
distaste for for higher protein diets
but you're not really enthusiastic about
going really high with it this would be
a suitable range for that particular use
case and then finally uh the range that
I call almost certainly sufficient so
this is 2 to 2.75 5 grams of protein per
kilogram of fat free mass and depending
on your body fat percentage this will
probably you know for a lot of folks
this will put you in a Range that's
going to be around 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram of total body mass
and so this is kind of getting into that
better safe than sorry range for someone
who is really adamant about optimizing
muscle gain or optimizing the retention
of muscle mass and really doesn't mind
consuming a pretty high protein diet you
know so it comes down ultimately to
priority and preference when you're
selecting one of these kind of Target
ranges and those are the factors you
want to consider how much do I like
consuming a high protein diet and how
adamant am I about optimizing and making
sure that I'm taking a better safe than
sorry approach when it comes to building
or maintaining lean mass now those
ranges You could argue that they should
all be bumped up a little bit when you
are cutting and the magnitude of that
bump is probably going to be dependent
on how aggressively you're cutting and
how lean you're getting so what I mean
by that is if you're doing like a pretty
modest weight loss phase you know really
focused on losing fat but not going
super fast with it you're not super lean
yet you might consider bumping all those
numbers up by 0.2
so 1.5 becomes 1.7 2.0 becomes 2.2 now
if you're going very very aggressively
if you're in a really aggressive diet
and your very very lean already so what
we're talking about here basically is if
you are getting ready for a photo shoot
like a fitness model photo shoot if you
are getting ready for a bodybuilding
competition or a physique competition
you're probably pushing pretty hard at
the end and you're probably already very
lean when you're pushing very hard at
the end and pushing in terms of trying
to get more fat loss to occur so in that
case you might actually bump these
targets up by instead of 0.2 you might
bump them up by 0.35 so that that
highest category that almost certainly
sufficient category would actually bump
up it would go from 2.35 to about 3.1
grams per kilogram of fat free Mass
which is a range that is very very
compatible with the range from a
systematic review published by the good
doctor Eric Helms I think it was back in
2 2014 it's been a number of years now
but uh obviously Dr Helms loves
bodybuilding and he published a
systematic review looking at you know in
that particular situation not
necessarily competitive bodybuilders but
shredded people who are trying to still
get leaner and diet pretty aggressively
you know how much protein do they really
need in order to optimize their ability
to retain muscle mass and fat-free mass
and it was higher than the typical range
that you would need in order to just
build muscle in a caloric deficit or
something like that and so that that
range that I mentioned if we bump these
numbers up by 0.35 and we settle on a
range where if you want to be absolutely
you know better safe than sorry really
focused on optimization it would go up
to 2.35 all the way up to 3.1 grams per
kilogram of fat free mass and so
that gives a couple ideas of you know
how you would go about setting a protein
Target and then of course the way that
you adjust it is going to depend on how
your diet's going right so you might say
that you want to start out
um you might be starting out with plenty
of body fat to lose
um you might be starting out with a
really conservative approach to weight
loss not pushing things too fast so
you're not you're not super lean yet
you're not super aggressive with your
dietary approach you might say you know
what I'm going to start out about 1.8
grams per kilogram of fat free Mass over
time as your likelihood of losing lean
mass accelerates because you know maybe
you're getting much leaner starting to
get pretty shredded starting to get more
aggressive with your your approach to
Fat Loss you might find that over the
course of your diet you're actually
pushing it upward a little bit and it's
going up into the two 2.4 or 2.8 even up
even you know maybe a little upwards of
three grams per kilogram of fat at free
Mass so we can see this kind of natural
incremental process that you could elect
to take as your diet progresses
now moving on to Fat
um
going to keep this one pretty brief and
there's a good reason for that uh when
you look at the literature on how low
fat can go on a diet this is the area
where I think there is the least
evidence to really lean on now we know
that if you go too low with your fat for
too long you can run into some potential
issues right so for example one of the
ones that comes up a lot is low
production of sex hormones so we might
see for example that testosterone starts
to really drop off if we go very very
low with fat intake for a sustained you
know long-term period of time now the
problem with fat though is if we go too
high with it during a fat loss phase
this is going to displace other
important nutrients right so if we if
we're just really enthusiastic about
having plenty of fat in a weight loss
diet that's okay and there are people
who have very successful weight loss on
very high fat diets when you look at the
ketogenic diet literature but the
problem is there for a lot of folks it's
going to displace protein and
carbohydrate in the diet to an extent
that they're really not happy with you
know if you're not really committed to a
ketogenic diet and your fat is a little
higher than it should be when you're
dieting you know doing a weight loss
diet you might you might start to really
feel like you're missing out on some of
the benefits of adding more protein or
adding more carbohydrate so the question
is
how low is too low and it really comes
down to a matter of perspective right so
if you're talking about just avoiding
short-term serious Adverse Events you
know that is something where you can
look at the literature and you'll
actually find some very very uh low fat
intake so for I mentioned earlier in
this episode some of the clinical weight
loss literature you're going to see
people on 800 calorie diets and you can
imagine the fat intake is not going to
be high right you got to get your
protein in there's going to be some
carbohydrate if you're on an 800 calorie
diet you just don't have enough calories
to work with to to pretend that you're
going to have some really you know high
fat approach so um I have seen some
literature indicating that in that
specific use case of a medically
supervised very low calorie diet there
have been some uh some arguments in the
literature of okay how much fat do we
really need to have and sometimes you'll
eat see numbers that get as low as 10 to
15 grams a day now I would never
recommend that as a sustainable weight
loss approach I would never in a million
years give someone a diet and so yeah 10
grams of fat a day 15 grams of fat a day
perfect that's fine I would never go
that low I wouldn't feel good about it I
would have concerns about other things
aside from just you know really serious
acute adverse effects I'd be starting to
worry in the longer term
about if we're just giving the body the
nutrients that it needs are we really
eating enough fat to facilitate suitable
absorption of fat soluble vitamins are
we taking in all the raw materials we
need to support you know proper uh you
know building of of cells themselves are
we bringing in enough essential fatty
acids to make sure that we've got just
our most basic nutrient needs being met
I would never and then of course like I
said the hormone element you know if
you're going 10 or 15 grams a day for an
extended period of time that's going to
have very very predictable negative
consequences on sex hormone production
and circulating levels of sex hormones
so I would never go that low and then
the question is well how low would I go
so for most uh weight loss diets a lot
of times there's two ways to look at it
you could look at it as a percentage of
total energy or you could look at
scaling it to body mass
uh and in this case I'm going to go
total body mass rather than fat free
Mass just to be super clear about that
so normally if I'm working with somebody
or you know talking about a diet I'd
like for fat
um to the extent possible to be
somewhere in the range of 20 to 35
percent of total energy now if they just
love a high fat diet and they want to go
above that fine you know there's there's
nothing wrong with that but usually 20
to 35 percent of total calories from fat
is kind of a very comfortable zone for
me uh if we want to scale that and just
talk about grams per kilogram of body
mass because sometimes you will have
people on really high calorie diets when
they're bulking and say well that that
range isn't really quite as critical
anymore if you just want to go and you
know you start to notice that just to
hit that bottom percentage you might be
having them consume more fat than they
like to consume
um so you might instead say well let's
talk about grams of car grams of fat per
kilogram of body mass and usually I try
to keep people in a range of 0.7 to 1.5
grams of fat per kilogram of body mass
now of course there are going to be
exceptions
um especially if you're talking about a
physique athlete uh getting down really
low in a diet competition is coming up
you know diets is getting really really
restrictive
um you know you you want to make sure
that there's plenty of protein in the
diet so they're preserving muscle mass
you want to make sure there's plenty of
carbs in the diet so they're still able
to train really effectively uh you know
sometimes on the tail end of a contest
prep you are going to see it get down to
0.6.5 grams per kilogram of body mass
that does happen and then and sometimes
people just really like a lot of fat
you'll go above 1.5 but
one of the most common questions I get
about fat aside from you know what's
kind of the typical range during a
cutting diet you know like I mentioned
20 to 35 percent of total energy or you
know 0.7 ish to 1.5 grams per kilogram
of body mass
um and sometimes going a little below
0.7 for short periods of time but aside
from those General ranges sometimes
people will ask me okay what what is
just the lowest that you will go because
I said 10 and 15 grams I'm not going
there it's not a number that I feel good
about not at all
um so my lower boundary
and I have published this uh in our our
diet article what I like to do is base
it on height
um and so it's all based on it's
relative to a height of 150 centimeters
so if you're shorter than 150
centimeters the lowest I would ever
really recommend going with fat
um it would be 30 grams a day that
that's the lowest that I would ever feel
good about uh saying oh yeah that looks
that looks okay
um now of course you know they're
they're always uh exceptions to that but
you know generally speaking I don't like
to go below 30 grams a day for just
about anybody
um now if you're above 150 centimeters
tall then there is an equation that you
can use so you would take your height in
centimeters you would subtract 150
you would divide that value by 2 and
then you would add 30. so for example if
you're 180 centimeters tall subtract 150
you get a value of 30. you divide that
by 2 that's 15 you add 30 which is just
a constant in the formula 45 grams of
fat would be your minimum so whatever
your height is subtract 50 subtract 150
divide that by 2 add 30 and from my
perspective that's about as low as I
ever like to go with fat
now where did that equation come from
it's not sitting there in a study okay
this is me just kind of piecing together
literature and trying to find a
generalizable heuristic that seems to
set a very good lower boundary for folks
that seems to be compatible with the
evidence that I've seen so you're not
going to be able to go out and find a
singular study that says we use this
equation it's the perfect formula and
everyone was better off for it this is
kind of a a heuristic that is informed
by the evidence but is not directly
empirically validated nor is it pulled
directly from an empirical study in
humans
uh and then finally uh the question the
next question would be carbohydrate
um you know how high should it be when
dieting normally with dieting the
approach I take is I start by setting a
protein Target then I set a fat Target
that is above that minimum and somewhere
within that range I feel comfortable
with uh protein is set fat is set and
then the rest of calories are coming
from carbohydrate
the reason I like to do that is assuming
that you're lifting or doing some form
of exercise and you want to do that
exercise quite well if it's you know
higher duration higher intensity
anything that's really an intensity
greater than a jog and being done at a
considerable level in terms of the
volume that you're doing on a weekly
basis or the intensity you know if
you're doing a lot of exercise you
probably want to make sure you're
getting plenty of carbs in your diet and
when you're in a weight loss diet you
really want to try to make as much room
for that as you can while still hitting
your preferences for protein and fat now
there's a lot of debate among lifters
about how much is enough for
carbohydrate usually what I say is if
you're doing a decent amount of
glycolytic activity like I said an
intensity greater than a jog uh you know
doing it for extended periods of time if
we're talking about cardio if you're
doing you know bodybuilding type
workouts or CrossFit type workouts or
circuit based workouts you probably want
to try to get plenty of carbs in your
diet if you can swing it if you have
enough calories to work with the number
I like is somewhere between three and
four grams of carbohydrate per kilogram
of body mass I like to keep it at three
or above for as long as I can during a
weight loss diet
and for someone who really prioritizes
their high intensity exercise
performance or for someone who just
really likes carbohydrate I really try
to squeeze as many carbs into the diet
as I possibly can but ultimately
calories are going to get low that is
the nature of dieting for weight loss
and so at a certain point something's
got to give you're not going to get down
into the the later stages of a weight
loss attempt and say okay I'm going to
give up a bunch of protein and sacrifice
lean mass retention just to kind of get
extra carbs in that's usually not going
to be an advisable trade-off for most
cases same thing if you're if your fat
intake is already kind of at knee at or
near that lower level you're probably
not going to want to dip below that
lower level just to kind of squeeze in
more carbs usually what I do as a weight
loss diet progresses is my protein will
either stay where it is or it might
drift upward a little bit depending on
the circumstances
I usually early in the diet will start
chipping away and taking calories away
from fat rather than carbohydrate
because I want to leave some of those
carbs in the diet to the best you know
to the best of my ability at a certain
point something's got to give you know
protein is as low as you want it to be
fat is as low as you want it to be and
the carbs are just going to have to give
and so sometimes I will get into
situations where at the end of a really
intense diet especially in a
bodybuilding context or physique athlete
context the carbs are just going to get
pretty low and it's just so we can
preserve our protein and fat as much as
we can
okay moving on to a another question
here question number four is how worried
should I be about metabolic adaptation
this is a super prevalent common
question uh for people that are about to
embark on a weight loss diet
and my answer how worried should you be
the answer is not not at all
um what I would encourage people to do
in terms of metabolic adaptation is to
be informed but not worried okay uh and
the reason for that we've covered uh
metabolic adaptation many times in
articles in podcasts the most recent
time that I've talked in detail about
metabolic adaptation
was actually uh a podcast segment and an
article about reverse dieting you can
find that article at macrofactorapp.com
reverse dieting and you know over the
years I first started uh doing research
on metabolic adaptation probably in 2013
um you know and then published my first
paper on it in 2014 and I've been
talking about it and writing about it
ever since and My Views certainly have
evolved
um
and and the literature itself has has
evolved quite a bit
um even just looking over the last few
years uh in particular there's a
researcher of the last name Martens who
has published a number of very
Illuminating studies on the topic of
metabolic adaptation you know back in
the day people were wondering uh or in
doing a lot of research on you know does
metabolic adaptation exist and the
answer is yes when people do weight loss
diets there is often an Adaptive
reduction in total daily energy
expenditure that exceeds the reduction
that we would anticipate based on
changes in body composition so there is
an Adaptive process happening it is
greater than zero this kind of extra
reduction in energy expenditure it
exists and um and the vast majority of
folks are are pretty solidly convinced
of that these days it's usually not a uh
not a lot of debate about whether or not
it exists the question is what is its
impact how much does it matter how much
should a person be worried about it and
like I said I don't think people should
be worried about it I think they should
be informed about it they should expect
that it's going to happen they should
know that the magnitude of metabolic
adaptation tends to be quite variable
from person to person so we cannot
easily predict exactly how big it's
going to be
um but the most important thing is that
it is constrained it's you know you're
not going to have 3 000 calories worth
of metabolic adaptation you're not going
to reach a point where you're on an 800
calorie diet and you just cannot lose
weight
um you know there there will always be a
calorie number where further weight loss
is possible uh and so and so yeah
sometimes people worry if metabolic
adaptation has completely shut the door
on their goals for weight loss and the
answer is virtually always no uh you
know the door is not shut there is still
a calorie Target that will be suitable
for continued weight loss so when we
talk about metabolic adaptation like I
said I I talk about it a lot in that
reverse dieting article and the
important thing to understand is that
metabolic adaptation exists and it adds
a little bit of friction and what I mean
by that is when we look at a study and
we actually separate out
who are the people that experienced a
lot of metabolic adaptation and who are
the people that experienced very little
metabolic adaptation there are
differences right so the people who
experience a lot of metabolic adaptation
within a study are likely to lose less
weight over a fixed timeline if
everyone's doing the same intervention
the people who have the most metabolic
adaptation often experience a little bit
less weight loss over that timeline
it's not zero I they still have a
tendency especially in the study I'm
thinking of uh by Martins and colleagues
which I do cite in that article about
reverse dieting you know they have shown
you know the people with a lot of
metabolic adaptation you know maybe they
only lost 11 kilograms in the study and
the people with very minimal metabolic
adaptation you know maybe they lost 14
kilograms but everybody had a very
successful weight loss process but yeah
there was a little bit of extra friction
where the folks experiencing more
metabolic adaptation probably would have
needed to make some bigger changes to
get this same exact amount of total
weight loss compared uh you know to
people who were experiencing less
metabolic adaptation
the other thing another way to look at
that friction in a different study by
Martins and colleagues is that they they
did a study where they were just looking
you know not at who loses more weight
over a fixed period of time but everyone
has a particular weight loss goal that
is you know standardized so everyone has
the same same general goal and the
question is who gets there the most
quickly and so another way to look at
that friction is that people who
experience the most metabolic adaptation
it's not that they never got to that
weight loss goal it's that they needed a
little bit more time but we're only
talking about a matter of a few weeks in
most cases so you know if someone were
to say hey what is the worst case
scenario for my metabolic adaptation if
I say you know how you wanted to lose 14
kilograms in the next six months you're
only going to lose 11. you know not
ideal it's not what they wanted to hear
but but you know that 11 kilograms is
not nothing it's not like metabolic
adaptation has closed the door on a
successful uh making successful strides
toward the weight loss goal same thing
if someone said you know what you can
still achieve the goal that you wanted
but because you experience kind of a
higher than average amount of metabolic
adaptation you know a lot of people
could get there in six months but it's
going to take you seven
a lot of people would say okay not what
I wanted to hear but certainly not
devastating not a massive massive issue
so one of the important things to keep
in mind is yes metabolic adaptation
exists yes it can add friction to the
process but something that's really
important to remember
is that metabolic adaptation is not
reliably predictive of weight loss
success so when they do these studies
and they say okay we're going to do a
one year or a two year or a six-year
follow-up you know they do a weight loss
intervention they measure who had a lot
of metabolic adaptation who had very
little and then they look at okay one
year after the intervention who regained
the most weight two years after six
years after who is regaining the most
weight uh after these weight loss
interventions
it is not the people who experience the
most metabolic adaptation uh it's very
intuitive to assume that if you
experience a lot of metabolic adaptation
you are going to end the diet with lower
energy expenditure and you are going to
be set up for a scenario where you are
much more likely to regain a lot of a
lot of weight and a lot of fat very
quickly it's very intuitive to make that
assumption but the empirical data the in
the controlled trials would indicate
that is not the case the folks who
experience metabolic adaptation during
that trial it is not reliably predictive
of their long-term success or their
long-term ability to maintain the weight
loss that they achieved there are simply
much more important factors that are
predicting long-term weight loss success
adhering to sustainable lifestyle
modifications that is huge uh eating
Behavior characteristics you know having
a really positive relationship with food
and being able to implement dietary
restraint in a very uh using flexible
cognitive of restraint right so being
able to reduce and manage your calorie
intake in a way that's sustainable and
flexible and something that can persist
in the long term
the incorporation of satiety promoting
strategies making sure that you're
actually leveraging food selection as a
key variable to help you out
so making sure that you're you're doing
a nice job during that weight
maintenance phase of selecting food
items that generally speaking are
supporting higher satiety and lower
hunger retaining lean mass actually
seems to be a pretty reliable predictor
of weight regain and that might sound
confusing but there are now multiple
studies indicating that people who lose
more fat free mass or lose more lean
mass during a diet tend to regain more
weight after that dieting phase is over
so if if they look at like a one year or
a two year follow-up period the people
who regain the most weight are the
people who lost the most fat free Mass
during the actual diet and there's
pretty compelling evidence that
the loss of fat free Mass seems to
independently be a driver of hunger and
so what what is the most likely scenario
is that individual who are losing fat
free Mass are experiencing heightened
levels of hunger during that weight
maintenance phase and so as a result
they are more likely uh you know to be
predisposed to Greater amounts of weight
regain
and fortunately a high protein diet
during the weight loss phase coupled
with a good resistance training program
can very strongly attenuate the loss of
lean mass during a diet uh two other
things that are very helpful and
actually are quite predictive of
long-term success regular
self-monitoring so just weighing
yourself on a regular basis just
tracking your calories on a regular
basis it keeps you in touch with how
things are going so that when body
weight starts drifting up when calorie
intake starts drifting up you notice it
before there's been a substantial
accumulation of of fat mass or or body
weight and so you can get in and kind of
study the ship before you feel like
you've really collapsed your motivation
you know if you feel like you've thrown
away a lot of the progress that you had
previously made sometimes that can
actually be have a really strong
demotivating effect that causes this
kind of snowball where you start to lose
touch with some of the things that
helped you lose that weight in the first
place and then finally the the other
thing I wanted to mention was just
plenty of physical activity physical
activity seems to be a very reliable
predictor that supports
the successful maintenance of a reduced
body weight after a weight loss phase
and so if you're able to keep your
physical activity level up that seems to
be a very very helpful thing and that
seems to be reliably shown in the
research and physical activity it's
important to recognize it's not just
lifting weights right so lifting weights
of course is a really great way to get
physical activity but we're also
incorporating
non-exercise physical activity so just
being active throughout the day getting
a relatively High Step count uh having a
step count goal in the first place is
another form of self-monitoring that
should be helpful so getting up
throughout the day limiting long periods
of sedentary time getting some steps in
throughout the day resistance training
of course is great you know structured
cardio of course that's great as well
but physical activity can take a lot of
different forms and frankly can be a
very very enjoyable thing you know
physical activity doesn't have to be uh
being on a treadmill two hours a day it
can be taking a hike through a lovely
park it can be kayaking it can be a lot
of things that you genuinely love to do
and simply keep you active
now a couple more here uh and I'm gonna
try to go through these a little bit
more quickly uh because they are kind of
more Niche topics
um and they're topics that we've covered
at length on the podcast before uh
number five here out of six when it
comes to these common questions number
five is should I use non-linear dieting
strategies
and what I mean there is refeeds cheat
days uh diet breaks
um maintenance phases all these types of
things that kind of break up the
linearity of a weight loss phase so
instead of just going straight through
having the same calorie Target every
single day and just you know gradually
going down and down and down sometimes
people like to incorporate these
non-linear strategies where calorie
intake actually goes up for a period of
time whether it's a day two days three
days could be a month could be more than
a month you know there are a number of
different non-linear strategies that
involve temporarily increasing the
calorie Target and then eventually
getting back to lower calorie targets
and kind of oscillating back and forth
so first of all refeeds generally
speaking this is something that most
commonly is used in the physique athlete
world the bodybuilding World a lot of
times during prep people will have one
maybe two sometime times three days a
week where they bump up their um their
calorie intake mostly from carbohydrate
uh from my perspective looking at the
the available literature
sometimes this is framed as something
that is going to attenuate metabolic
adaptation I used to have higher hopes
that that might be the case as more data
have become available I am losing
optimism in that particular outcome I'm
much more inclined to say that refeeds
are mostly for two outcomes one would be
performance in the gym the other would
just be having a little bit of variety
during a tightly controlled diet you
know so for example you might have a
physique athlete who's on really low
calories and they say hey
if I could just have one or two days a
week where there's a little more
flexibility in the diet psychologically
that would be a really helpful thing to
me that would be a very very uh valid
reason to incorporate refeeds another
would be you have a physique athlete
who's training legs twice a week and
their legs are kind of their weak point
they really are trying to make sure that
they bring that muscle group up or maybe
they're just you know they need to make
sure that they're maintaining everything
they got as their prep continues
theoretically you could strategically
use those refeeds in close proximity to
the most critical workouts of the week
so that they're going into the gym
feeling very well fed very energized and
they can really give it their best
effort uh in those specific workouts so
I think there are some psychological
benefits I think there are some benefits
pertaining to just kind of acute
enhancements and performance but are you
know is having one or two refeeds a week
gonna totally keep metabolic adaptation
at Bay probably not is it going to
meaningfully affect the proportion of
weight that is lost as fat Mass versus
fat free Mass probably not in terms of a
Global Perspective but if you can
enhance a couple key workouts per week
perhaps there's a regional effect where
you're able to hold on to a little bit
more lower body mass because you
strategically put your refeeds near your
lower body days there there's some
possibility of that but we're really
mostly talking about psychological
advantages and performance advanced
manages that are very acute in nature
we're not talking about blunting
metabolic adaptation to a meaningful
degree next would be cheat days
um very very common in the fitness world
I wrote an article all about them so I'm
not going to get too into the details
about cheat days
um if you go to macrofactorapp.com cheat
meals I talk all about the shortcomings
and the issues you might run into if
you're utilizing a lot of cheat days or
cheat meals and what I do is I offer
what I consider to be a better
alternative based on the evidence
available so I do believe that what we
would call a planned hedonic deviation
offers all of the purported upsides of a
cheat day but with uh much fewer
downsides I I do very strongly believe
that a planned hedonic deviation is
meaningfully different than a cheat day
and also meaningfully better than a
cheat day and what we're doing with a
planned hedonic deviation is for for
psychological reasons or just for
lifestyle flexibility we are consciously
allocating a little bit of extra calorie
intake to a particular day so a great
example would be if there is a
particular social Act activity where you
want to have a little more dietary
flexibility you can build that into your
weekly plan you don't feel like you're
cheating on your diet because it is
literally built into the diet and plan
for and accounted for so I do think that
planned hedonic deviations are much much
more favorable and they are purely for
psychological benefit lifestyle benefit
now the next one would be diet breaks or
intermittent maintenance phases and the
distinction there is arbitrary so a diet
break could be as long as you want
normally in the Fitness World they might
be one week or two weeks but
theoretically it could be as long as you
want and so when does a diet break
become so long that you just call it a
maintenance phase I don't know it could
be a month or two months who knows but
basically what we're talking about here
is you are pausing the diet essentially
and bringing your calories back up to a
maintenance level so you're losing
weight losing weight losing weight you
bring them back up and you just
stabilize weight for some predetermined
period of time it I guess it doesn't
necessarily have to be predetermined you
might say hey I'm going to do a diet
break and I'm going to resume a weight
loss phase or kind of get back into a
caloric deficit when I feel ready so
that certainly is an option now the
question is is there a physiological
Advantage here that makes diet breaks
more effective for fat loss more
effective for uh you know attenuating or
preventing metabolic adaptation there
was one study called The Matador study
that is the most promising evidence that
would suggest that there is a
physiological Advantage where diet
breaks enhance fat loss
and diet breaks attenuate metabolic
adaptation it was a very good study it
was done very well but when you look at
the results uh numerically speaking
quantitatively speaking
it's a virtual certainty that the
differences
caused in terms of total daily energy
expenditure metabolic rate all that
stuff about metabolic adaptation the
effects on metabolic rate were not
nearly large enough to describe the
differences between groups where the
diet break group for some reason lost a
lot more fat than the group that just
did a diet straight through the most
likely scenario is that the advantage
was behavioral psychological just just
providing more flexibility in the diet
and giving people an opportunity to
pause take their breath get out of that
deficit and then re-enter at a later
date so when we look at the totality of
the evidence on diet breaks and
maintenance phases there seem to be some
small benefits for some people in terms
of the amount of weight lost over the
course of a direct over the duration of
an intervention but the Main benefits
appear to be psychological more than
anything it seems to be
something that is psychologically and
behaviorally advantageous in a way that
supports dietary adherence so it's
increasingly the more that research
comes out and I actually had had a the
opportunity to collaborate on a diet
break study and I've been really tapped
into this literature for the last few
years when we look at that literature
very closely uh what you know the more
that you look at the totality of it it's
very difficult to suggest that diet
breaks or maintenance phases are having
some huge physiological advantage or
some huge Advantage where they are
totally blunting metabolic adaptation it
appears that they are tools that can
help with psychological aspects of
dieting and they can help with dietary
adherence that seems to be the primary
benefit that we're observing in the
literature the physiological benefits
are very hit and miss and hard to really
have a lot of confidence in at this
point in time and that that is uh an
area where my perspectives have really
changed over time uh the more that I've
been involved in that research so I used
to have a lot of hope that diet breaks
would really effectively attenuate
metabolic adapt adaptation over the
course of a weight loss diet
um now I view them more as an adherence
tool a behavioral tool and a
psychological tool but it's really
critical to remember that from a
psychological perspective diet breaks
and maintenance phases
will be very beneficial to some
individuals and can actually be
counterproductive for others and the
reason I say that is because there are a
lot of folks who once they get some
momentum going and they see that they're
achieving weight loss and weight is
going down and down and down over time
when you disrupt that momentum and say
hey now that we've got weight loss
rolling let's stop
and let's not be losing weight for a
little bit sometimes that disruption of
the momentum can be a very demotivating
thing and the Dieter can feel like they
are continuously getting pulled back and
forth and back and forth uh weight loss
weight maintenance weight loss weight
maintenance it could be very very tiring
fatiguing frustrating and it will seem
like the second they get things going in
the right direction they're pausing
again for some individuals it can
actually backfire and be psychologically
um counterproductive okay and so that's
something that's really important to
keep in mind uh if you are thinking
about using diet breaks or maintenance
phases you want to think very carefully
about your psychological makeup you know
you have to know yourself or if you're a
coach working with a client you have to
know your client and say is this going
to be something where they really enjoy
the enhanced flexibility and it makes
this diet just a little bit more
flexible and enjoyable
do they need a little break every now
and then just to kind of
pause take their you know catch their
breath and then keep going or is this
the type of client where once we get the
motivation going the best thing we can
possibly do is keep it going so there
are some clients where a diet break can
be an extremely valuable tool and there
are some clients where it is not the
right tool and it can actually backfire
more than it helps
um the last thing I want to address here
is something that's been asked very very
frequently lately and the question is
how long can you do a cut or a weight
loss phase before you need to either do
a diet break or a maintenance phase or
even switch to a bulking diet like how
long can you do a cut or a weight loss
phase continuously
and I know that a lot of folks that I
have a lot of respect for have put out
heuristics of you know well maybe you
should only cut for this many weeks at a
time or that many months at a time and
um that's okay you know I'm not trying
to be hyper critical in this uh segment
but I've never seen convincing evidence
to me that would indicate that there's
any cap on how long you can do a
successful weight loss phase as long as
you are taking an incremental approach
and you're adjusting your calorie Target
over time to make sure you're
facilitating a suitable and sustainable
rate of weight loss I don't see any
reason to really put a time constraint
on how long a dieting phase can be and
so when people ask me how long can I cut
before I have to switch things up or
take a break I say literally as long as
you want there there's from a
physiological perspective there's really
no such thing as needing a break from
this kind of weight loss diet so
um there are folks who you know they
might give heuristics and say
you should only diet for you know three
months or four months or five months at
a time because just from a practical
perspective you're gonna be over it you
know you're gonna say hey I need to take
a break here I'm a little bit burnt out
so there are some heuristics that I
think are just being dictated by you
know for most people what seems to be an
enjoyable weight loss experience but
when it comes down to just pure
physiology is there a cap on how long a
Diet phase can be
based on all the evidence I've seen the
answer would be no you can keep going uh
to the extent that you wish to and for a
lot of folks I say hey when you've got
momentum going and you still have fat
that you want to lose and things are
going well and you want to keep going
further there's no reason that you
should feel like you're unable to keep
going further as you know as long as
you're doing things in a healthy and
sustainable way you're more than welcome
to keep going
and now the final question I want to
address and this one will be a bit brief
because it's something that has been a
PR uh
it's something that's been covered on
the podcast and just an aggressively
long segment uh this was one of those
segments I think it's my my worst ever
estimate of how long I thought a segment
would be versus how long it had ended up
being uh I think I probably went for a
good hour and 40 minutes talking about
reverse dieting and I really believe
that I could wrap that thing up in about
30 minutes or so uh so hey my mistake I
was wrong on that but the good thing is
if you want to really deep dive into
reverse dieting that segment and the the
corresponding article take a much deeper
dive than anyone would possibly want to
see so um the the sixth and final
question I want to address in this
particular episode is should I reverse
diet and people are going to ask that
for for in many different circumstances
so should I reverse diet
before I do a cut you know do I need to
prepare my metabolism for a successful
cut another question is do I need to
reverse diet after I complete my weight
loss goal is this like a mandatory or
necessary or extremely advantageous
strategy to transition from a weight
loss phase into a long-term maintenance
phase so those are the two most common
applications of this question should I
reverse diet so the question should I
reverse Diet before a cut in order to
kind of prepare my metabolism and you
know theoretically make that diet a
little easier make it so that I can diet
on higher calories than I otherwise
would be able to uh my answer to that
would be no I do not think that you need
to reverse Diet before a cut
uh and of course like I said I've gone
into a lot of detail elsewhere about
that but there are a number of points uh
to be made here number one uh your
resting metabolic rate or your total
daily energy expenditure at the start of
a cut does not seem to be reliably
predictive of weight loss success so it
is not true to say that if you could
only get your metabolic rate higher then
we can say that you know you should be
more successful in a subsequent weight
loss phase that claim doesn't seem to be
very compatible with the available
evidence another question or another
point to be made I should say is that
having higher resting metabolic rate or
total energy expenditure at the start of
a cut does not necessarily mean that you
will maintain a higher metabolic rate or
energy expenditure throughout the entire
cut so just because you're able to
theoretically do some overfeeding or
reverse dieting that starts to cause
your energy expenditure to go up for a
diet
any progress that you're making in that
regard the evidence would suggest that
is not going to be a durable change
you're not going to be able to increase
it before the diet and then have that
increase persist as you transition into
a weight loss phase what we tend to see
in the literature is
even if you were able to have a high
work your metabolic rate higher before
the diet the second that you go into a
caloric deficit and a weight loss phase
there's no reason for us to believe that
any gain in metabolic rate would
actually persist and survive that
transition as you get into the next
weight loss phase that the increase in
energy expenditure that we might observe
during an overfeeding strategy if we
want to call it reverse dieting that
seems to be an extremely short-term
extremely transient effect and once you
exit that that overfeeding or reverse
dieting strategy it goes away it
vanishes you don't get to just hang on
to that forever
um and and then finally what we notice
is that
um you know when we talk about people
with Thrifty metabolic phenotypes these
are people who experience the most
metabolic adaptation the largest drops
in energy expenditure over the course of
a diet they actually tend to have
resting metabolic rates before they diet
when they're just at you know neutral
energy balance stable body weight their
metabolic rate and energy expenditure
tends to be as high if not higher than
folks who have less Thrifty phenotypes
so the idea that
you need to get your metabolic rate up
to start with and that's going to
protect you from a drop when you
transition to a dieting phase like I
said previously that doesn't seem to be
compatible with the literature having a
high degree of metabolic adaptation or a
particularly Thrifty phenotype is all
about how your body responds to the
change in energy status when you go from
positive or neutral to negative energy
balance so what we find is people with
Thrifty phenotypes people who experience
the greatest degree of metabolic
adaptation
they have smaller increases in energy
expenditure during overfeeding so
they're actually less likely to build up
their metabolic rate during a reverse
dieting type protocol so it's probably
not going to work very well even when
they're trying to over feed they're
going to be more likely to simply just
gain some fat during that reverse
dieting process but they're going to
have highest likelihood that gain during
that process lowest likelihood of any
meaningful increase in energy
expenditure and even if they did the
second they transition over into a
deficit that is when we're going to see
a pretty substantial drop in energy
expenditure and so there's really no
evidence to suggest that reverse dieting
before a cut is going to make that cut
more successful and it is least likely
to help the individuals who would
theoretically want it the most now the
other question like I said is
after I complete my weight loss goal
um is that a time where I need to
reverse diet uh you know is is this uh
something that is going to help me
transition uh into a more successful
long-term maintenance phase after my cut
is over and once again the answer uh
quite simply is no from my perspective
um in that article in that podcast
segment I go into a lot of detail about
the relevant research pertaining to this
question uh the short version is there's
really no evidence that it's
physiologically advantageous to do this
reverse diet as a transition into
maintenance again physiologically one
might say that there are potentially
behavioral advantages to that and that's
that's totally fine
um but but we don't really see any
physiological Advantage where reverse
dieting to maintenance would be any
better than just going straight to
maintenance calories and hanging out
there there's also some evidence that
you know if you want to make the claim
that this is going to help uh build up
metabolic rate or you want to make the
claim that this is going to help uh
ensure that a person maintains a leaner
Physique in the longer term uh there's
actually evidence that would uh in my
opinion directly contradict that set of
ideas uh probably the most striking
evidence is in the
um the the Minnesota starvation
experiment so what they did was they um
put a number of individuals through a
really aggressive semi-starvation
protocol and a small subset what they
did was in the controlled refeeding
period after the weight loss phase and
these individuals got very very lean you
could probably tell from the name of the
studies the starvation experiment right
but uh after the weight loss phase there
is a refeeding phase the first phase was
actually very well controlled and then
they said okay the controlled refeeding
phase is over now you're just left to
your own devices you can self-select
what you're going to eat and kind of eat
to your your heart's content you know
whatever you see fit and so in that
controlled refeeding period they had
several different rates at which
calories were increased and there are
two really important uh observations
from that experiment when it comes to
reverse dieting first of all the
individuals who were given the pretty
slow rate of reintroduction of calories
the the uh protocol that would look most
similar to what most people call reverse
dieting they were really struggling to
physiologically recover from the prior
diet and so the researchers said hey
this is way too slow these folks are not
physiologically recovering from the diet
the way we had hoped we're not
stimulating enough recovery we actually
need to start speeding things up so they
actually changed course during that
controlled refeeding period
now during that controlled period even
after they changed course you know they
had these four different levels of you
know the rate of caloric reintroduction
and the folks who introduced calories
very quickly of course they gained
considerably more weight than the
individuals who did a slower and more
gradual reintroduction of calories but
what was really interesting was what
happened after they just reverted uh
back to their their typical kind of
self-selected eating habits the folks
who went slower and essentially did
reverse dieting and essentially worked
quite hard to well it wasn't their
choice necessarily but the people who
did the work required to not regain a
lot of weight in that initial refeeding
period the moment that things became
less controlled and they were kind of
determining their own intake they caught
up with the other groups with the other
individuals so
they were able to delay the fat regain
because of the protocol they were doing
but once that reverse dieting phase
ended they very quickly caught up and
ended up with with a similar uh level of
weight regain and fat regain when
compared to the folks who said whatever
let's just go ahead and ramp these
calories up really quickly so
physiologically there was no advantage
that that would have enabled those
individuals to use a protocol like
reverse dieting to set themselves up for
a more success a more successful
maintenance phase or a leaner long-term
physique after that weight loss was
achieved and then finally one of the
main points I make in that article
and in the subsequent podcast segment
is that you know there's two options
that I compare here one is reverse
dieting the other is just simply jumping
straight to a maintenance calorie intake
that puts you at neutral energy balance
what we see is that the mere transition
of going from a caloric deficit to
neutral energy balance or energy
maintenance or weight maintenance I
should say when you go from a deficit to
neutral energy balance in many cases we
will start to see that some of the
metabolic adaptation the reduction in
energy expenditure will start to reverse
itself not because you're forcing it to
by making small incremental changes but
it is simply a natural thing that occurs
when you go from negative energy balance
to neutral when you go from an energy
deficit to maintenance and so one of the
points that I argue and I present a
number of calculations and citations to
support this is simply jumping to
maintenance
accomplishes the thing that a lot of
people are trying to do with reverse
dieting a lot of people after they
finish a diet they say I want to really
build up my metabolic rate so that I'm
able to consume higher calories
throughout this maintenance phase and
what we see is if they just jump to
maintenance they might find that over
time energy expenditure creeps up a
little bit and then they might say yeah
okay I jumped to maintenance but since
some of those metabolic adaptations
unraveled my energy expenditure actually
started to creep up so now I can
increase my calories again just to kind
of stay at maintenance rather than being
in an energy deficit again you basically
have to in many cases incrementally bump
your calories up just to stay at
maintenance because
metabolic adaptation starts to kind of
reverse itself when you go from negative
to neutral energy balance so to me the
big uh very pervasive myth about reverse
dieting is that people are
manipulating their energy expenditure or
that they are
forcing it up by doing these very small
meticulous nuanced changes in energy
intake in reality you can make a much
stronger case based on the evidence and
the physiological rationale that what is
happening is if they had simply jumped
to maintenance you know metabolic rate
energy expenditure probably would have
started to creep up just from doing that
and then they would have to increase
their calories again just to to keep up
with where their maintenance is and that
process would play out over time and
they would look back and say you know
what I incrementally was increasing my
calories it looks like I was reverse
dieting but those incremental increases
in calories were not causing metabolic
rate to go up they were happening
because metabolic rate was going up and
in order to maintain neutral energy
balance they had to just kind of keep
reacting by increasing their calorie
Target a little bit so um that all of
that is to say if you're really excited
about reverse dieting
um and you really want to do it
I have no interest in taking the wind
out of your sales or trying to convince
you that that it's a lost cause or that
it's uh you know there's some futility
associated with this I I do not think
it's an evidence-based approach that
that would have physiological benefits
but
I no one stands to benefit from me just
simply demotivating people about an
intervention that they're excited about
trying so uh if you want to try reverse
dieting there's certainly nothing wrong
with that and as long as not you're not
keeping yourself at very very low
calorie intakes for an indefensibly long
period of time generally speaking
there's just there's there's not really
significant downsides in most common
applications of reverse dieting so I
think the evidence is quite weak if
you're trying to support reverse dieting
I actually think reverse dieting is uh
quite contradictory to the evidence
that's available but you know in terms
of all the interventions out there as
like I said as long as you're not
staying at a really low body fat and a
very low calorie intake for an
indefensively indefensibly long period
of time there's nothing wrong with
saying you know what I don't know if
reverse dieting is going to work uh
probably isn't but I'm going to try it
because it interests me and honest
excited about it if you want to do that
that's completely fine
and in fact within macro factor in our
knowledge base we do have a bit of
information that says hey we don't
really think reverse dieting works in
the way it's it's often uh claimed to
work or or the way that people Market it
in terms of what it's supposed to be
doing we don't really believe that based
on the evidence but you know within
macro Factor you know because of that
we're not really comfortable saying
here's a reverse dieting feature or
function because we we feel like we
would be saying hey here's a thing that
we don't believe Works go ahead and try
it right but we do have information in
the knowledge base that says if you're
interested in this and you want to do it
here's a step-by-step guide on how you
would actually set that up within macro
Factor so the way that we designed the
app was to be really supportive and make
sure that we were empowering people to
uh to do the intervention that they
really want to do uh pursue the goals
that they want to pursue all we try to
do with the app is have really
non-judgmental guidance along the way
which is one of the reasons that we we
often refer to it as a diet sidekick
it's something that is supposed to be
supportive along the way
um and so if you want to do reverse
dieting the app of course there's still
a way for the app to support you very
effectively in that endeavor uh so
that wraps it up for this episode
um it was a little different this is a
different type of Stronger by science
podcast episode I certainly hope that
you've enjoyed it and I hope that you've
gotten something useful from it I I my
intention with this episode was that
whether you are just getting into
fitness or you're a seasoned veteran or
perhaps there are people that you care
about who are just getting into fitness
as the new year begins My Hope Is that
you could get something useful from this
episode or share it with somebody who
might get something useful from it as
well I know a lot of times there are you
know for a lot of Fitness enthusiasts
myself included there are people in our
life who uh as as the the New Year comes
around they start to say hey I'm
actually starting to take a bit of an
interest in this Fitness stuff where do
I get started my hope is that you know
this podcast might be a good resource
for someone to kind of sort through how
do I get started how do I get rolling
what are some common questions and more
importantly what are the answers to some
of those common questions so I I very
much do hope that you enjoyed it and
hope you got something useful out of it
uh our series will continue as we talk
about uh various ways to uh to kind of
start the new year on the right foot uh
just recapping we've talked about goal
setting motivation Behavior change
at this point uh with this episode we've
talked about some of the most common
questions about weight loss diets uh
moving forward we're going to talk a
little bit about cardio for weight loss
we're going to talk about what mindful
eating is and how it might be
incorporated into an evidence-based
eating strategy also going to talk a
little bit about the importance of sleep
sleep is something that you really
shouldn't sleep on it's it's a very
important variable and a lot of times
you know we get convinced that we can
just push through a lack of sleep and
pretend that we're unaffected by it but
when it comes to fitness goals as we'll
talk about sleep can be a really really
critical component of a well-rounded
approach to optimizing your Fitness
progress so sleep is not always easy to
manage it's not always easy to control
if we have sleep issues sometimes there
can be really really big challenges that
prevent us from getting more sleep but
nonetheless we're going to talk about
why sleep is important and strategies
for supporting really good sleep so that
does it for this episode as always thank
you so much for listening and we'll be
back soon with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]